so one of the great things about covid
is that nobody not a single person
was smart enough or strong enough to
escape any kind of Trauma from it
um that's what some people had it soon
some people had it later some people had
pieces of it and it sort of continues to
to be a steady drip some people had a
you know a a an intense depression
um but we all went through it which
means I hope
that we have more understanding and
empathy for the condition you know for
for mental health that that this is a
real thing that people go through and
sometimes they can't explain it you know
I think very often we want to know what
the reason what the cause is like you
know is it because you know uh you know
you have a sick family member is it
because you broke up with your your your
boyfriend or girlfriend like we we're
always looking for the cause and
sometimes it's not it's not there
um and I think it goes back to empathy
which is which is it's it's not for us
to fix it's for us to hold space
you know
um you know there's a very simple
question for for a leader which is
r-u-o-k
and this is something we have to do
whether we think someone's okay with us
we think somebody's not okay a lot of
people can mask
um how they're actually feeling they
double down on work to compensate you
know it's just because somebody's
productive and their performance is up
doesn't mean they're they're not
struggling
um and so I you know to create a space
where you can say are you okay and
actually care about the answer is a huge
test for leadership and by the way the
best way to achieve that is for the
leaders uh to lead by example and that's
very scary for for a lot of people in
leadership positions we talk about
vulnerability but the reality is if
they're not modeling the behavior other
people won't follow it you know if we
say you know we want to know how you how
you feel but I'm always in Tip-Top shape
and I'm always have all the answers and
I'm always strong well then I can
guarantee you that creates an
environment in which people actually are
afraid to be honest and so uh uh it's
it's it's necessary for people in
leadership positions whether it's on a
huddle or some other forum
or maybe you know to a few people and
say Hey listen I'm I'm struggling this
week and I just want I want to apologize
and say please be patient with me you
know I'm probably I'm I know I'm not at
my best I I think I might actually take
a Friday off because I'm I'm I'm I'm
having a hard time this week and I'm not
sure what it is but I know that I'm not
myself for Elita to be able to say that
creates an environment for somebody on
the team to come and say the same thing
and then we can hold space for them but
if the leader's lying hiding and faking
every day then all we're doing is
creating an environment where our people
will lie and fake every day and so you
know I think this idea of of leading
with vulnerability of and vulnerability
doesn't mean you're you know that
doesn't mean you're weak you know all it
means is you're willing to say something
that makes you uh like admit a mistake
ask for help say you don't understand
something or admit struggle that's all
it is that's all it is with the
confidence that people will be there to
hold space for you and support you and
if the leader is willing to do that it's
remarkable what we can create around us
for the people who work there